INSTRUCTOR: Hi,
Data 2100 students.
This lecture is one
of those lectures
that is necessary in the
world of information systems.
It's actually a topic
that many of you
can get a full degree
in project management.
Project management is a
philosophy, a principle content.
It's a practice, if you will,
that is heavily studied.
And as you get into your
perspective industry,
your career, you're
going to notice
that project management looks
different across the board
and from team to team.
So I just want to give you
some foundations of why
project management
matters, some ideas
based upon our reading of
why there's different project
management methodologies,
what they're both used for,
and especially in
the world of IT,
the systems
development life cycle.
So this is a very
high-level, brief video
about project management.
But there's seriously
degrees of--
I mean, so many jobs are
just project managers.
There's an element of project
management in every capacity
of every job that you work in.
Right now I'm working on
an analytic solution center
project, that I'm helping manage
the project that I'm working
on requirements gathering.
Those who are working
on the project
are working with me to
understand what the end user
would like from the project.
We're doing this
in an agile way.
So we're using all of
these tools and techniques
that you learn in this
class in a project
that students are
working on here at USU
So this is used in all sorts
of different capacities.
But why does project
management matter?
So project management
defines a plan and schedule.
So project management helps
in defining a clear plan
and schedule for the project.
We ensure that goals are met.
We optimize resource
allocation, so what resources
go where as far as budget,
time, human capacity.
We also improve
team collaboration.
So oftentimes, project
management looks like--
that you have clearly defined
roles and responsibility
of each person on the team,
and that we're working
towards that common goal.
We also can manage
risk and uncertainties.
There's always risk and
uncertainties with a project--
something can go wrong.
This proactive
approach helps minimize
the impacts of risks on
the outcome timelines,
and what have you.
It also enhances
customer satisfaction.
So us delivering
a project on time
and within budget enhances
customer satisfaction.
So we have the systems
development life cycle.
There are seven steps within
that systems development life
cycle.
First off, we start by
planning the project.
So we lay out what does
this project look like,
who's involved, what
are the requirements.
We then analyze the project.
We design the project.
So maybe this looks like
you're developing a website,
and you're going to be
developing a wireframe.
A wireframe of a
website is basically
the bare bones of a website
that shows you, here's what
the first page will look like.
And there's a diagram
that maybe is interactive.
Then we develop that website.
So based upon feedback
that we've been receiving,
we can push to development.
Then we test it.
Does the website work
like we want it to?
We can then implement the
website and then maintain it.
So this is not necessarily
just specific to IT,
but it does use technical terms.
But in general, this is what
a life cycle of a project
looks like.
So there's three main
developments within the systems
development life cycle.
The development phase is in
the development environment.
So make sure you know that.
The quality assurance--
so quality assurance
is what QA stands for.
That's where we test.
Does this work like we
think it should be working?
Like it should be working right.
And then we finally
implement this.
We put it into
production, meaning people
can utilize this website.
They can purchase
things on this website.
This is pushed out into the
greater public, if you will,
to be able to be used, or
if it's an internal project
that those end users
then can finally
use whatever you just produced.
We also have two ideas
of project management.
So we have the agile approach
and the waterfall approach.
The agile methodology is
really helpful for when
you're starting a project.
The client really
isn't sure what
they want at the
beginning of the project.
Sometimes this looks like--
I had my own website development
company for some time,
and I would meet with
a client and based
upon what the client
was saying, like oh,
this is going to be
the agile approach.
The requirements of
the project weren't
really well-defined I'd
ask follow-up questions,
and it seemed like
there was some area
that they hadn't considered.
So with agile, basically, you
work through this entire systems
development life cycle
in a span of a sprint,
is what they're called.
So generally, sprints
are two weeks.
So at the first of that
two weeks you're planning,
what does this sprint need
to accomplish by the end?
So if you're working on, say,
a Contact Us page on a website,
you plan out that one page.
You analyze the needs,
you design the needs,
you develop that one page.
You test that one page.
You implement that one page.
And at that very end
of those two weeks,
you get feedback from your
client who says, oh, I
like this part of the page,
change that part of the page.
And you have a potentially--
we call it shippable product
by the end of that two weeks.
And then the next
two weeks, say you're
going to work on the home
page of the website, right.
So you're breaking
down the project
into its component parts.
And so you're getting
a ton of feedback
with the client on what's
working and what's not.
A waterfall is
more, so you're just
going through each of
these phases one time.
So maybe it's a security
system at a bank.
Say, it's somebody at
America First Bank,
and they're going around to
all the brick-and-mortar banks
to implement this
new security system.
If they've done it so
many times and it's really
well thought out--
it's very much a
lockstep approach--
then a waterfall may work.
And a waterfall looks
like I'm in the planning
phase for some time and the
analysis phase for some time,
in the design phase
for some time,
the development
phase for some time,
the testing phase for some
time, and implementation
phase for some time.
We do not circle
back up in waterfall.
Waterfall, you are in planning
phase for a period of time,
then you go into
analysis, then design.
So just keep that in mind.
There's those two
different phases.
Both have their pros and cons.
Generally, you're
going to see a mix.
But most teams are wanting to
be agile in their methodology.
Finally, the element of
scope creep with projects.
Part of this will look
like-- a lot of my examples
are websites or data
analysis projects.
But scope creep you
meet with the client.
They say, I want a website
that is four pages.
And so you work with them
over a series of sprints.
You meet with them
and then you can
start to see that they're
like, oh, actually,
we might want to
add another page,
or we might want to add another
capability on an existing page
that we didn't know about.
So that just means that the
project is growing and growing
and growing, which, if you can
communicate with the client,
is going to cost more money.
It's going to take
more resources.
It's going to take more time.
Then you can come to
some sort of agreement.
But scope creep oftentimes
is the fail of most projects
because you let it get so big
that you don't condense it down
into, OK, what is the
most important parts?
And be firm when you're
working in a project
and considering what is
originally part of this project
and what is being added to it
that we need to either save
for another project or up
the budget, up the timeline,
those types of things.
So that's a little bit
about project management.
Again, there is degrees in this.
There's whole careers
devoted to this,
but I just want you
to think about how
we manage big projects.
And you have projects going
on at either at your work
or in school that there is an
element of project management
that communication and making
sure those deliverables are
met on time.
But something to keep
in mind here as we're
setting information in business.
Take care, everybody.